des coups d'éclats mais cette fois-ci
c'est surpasser hier soir le nouveau
propriétaire de la plateforme sociale
Twitter a sondé l'opinion de ses 122
millions d'abonnés sa question dois-je
quitter la direction de Twitter ce matin
la décision est tombée 17 millions de
personnes ont voté et plus de 57%
veulent qui cesse de diriger Twitter un
réseau qui l'a acheté il y a à peine
deux mois pour 44 milliards de dollars
ce résultat est probablement en lien
avec les multiples décisions d'affaires
controversé qui Elon Musk prise depuis
son arrivée
c'est aussi un service collectif si je
peux dire alors la première chose que
Monsieur master en rentrant c'est de
mettre du monde à pied fermé les
départements qui étaient garant d'une
certaine hygiène informationnelle si
vous ne passez l'expression plusieurs
observateurs estiment que le
milliardaire n'est tout simplement pas
la bonne personne pour gérer
efficacement un média social moi je ne
pourrais jamais accepter puis je vais
souvent acquérir je pourrai jamais
accepter que des
multimilliardaires décident de qu'est-ce
qui est bon ou qu'est-ce qui est mauvais
à mettre sur un réseau social c'est
inadmissible mais on se retrouve dans
cette situation-là aujourd'hui ou ces
gens-là ont ce droit de vivre une mort
sur la liberté d'expression malgré les
résultats du sondage et la mosque n'a
pas encore officiellement annoncé qu'il
quittait la direction Twitter si les
conformes à sa parole il devra quitter
comme PDG mais qui c'est qui plus
embarquer là et surtout est-ce que
Monsieur masse va rester dans l'iPad du
nouveau PDG ou de la nouvelle PDG ici
normand Grondin Radio-Canada Montréal